during a vaginal childbirth the first  stage of labor lasts about 12 to 19  hours  and starts when your baby settles lower  into your pelvis  in response your cervix begins to efface  or become thinner and dilate or widen  during this time you may feel strong  regular contractions occurring every 5  to 20 minutes  and lower back pain and cramping that  doesn't go away  you may see a brownish or reddish mucous  discharge which could be the mucus plug  at the opening of your cervix falling  out  your water may break which can either be  a large gush of fluid or a continuous  trickle  if you experience any of these symptoms  contact your doctor or midwife to see if  you should go to the hospital